you
two-minute warning
hello everyone
president Trump will participate in a
roundtable to hear stories of families
positively impacted by law enforcement
that will be taking place shortly after
this briefing concludes the president
stands with our police officers our men
and women across this country who
valiantly patrol our streets and protect
our citizenry this president stands on
the side of law and order to secure
peace in our streets that his has always
been his priority and remains so today
tragically this weekend we saw a
devastating ambush attack against brave
law enforcement officers in McAllen
Texas officer Edel Medal Miro Garza jr.
who was 45 years old an officer ismael
chavez who is 39 years old and while
responding to a domestic disturbance
call
officers Garza and Chavez arrived on
scene to protect the people that they
serve they were met with gunfire they
were ambushed by a violent and dangerous
suspect who horrific ilish OTT before
they even drew their weapon or had a
chance to call for backup
we honor the lives in the service of
officer Garza and officer Chavez this
president will always stand on the side
of law enforcement and the heroes who
protect and serve and with that I'll
take questions to break records in the
most recent interview President Trump
did he said we are going to be in really
good shape in the next two to four weeks
can you share what evidence he's using
to draw that conclusion and what is the
administration going to do differently
in the next two to four weeks to stop
the spread so the one thing I would note
is that when you look at the mortality
rate we're seeing that our efforts here
at the federal government have been
working and to give you an example of
that when you look at New York in New
Jersey there were 21 deaths for every
thousand cases 20 deaths for every
thousand cases in the case of New Jersey
those were the ratios we were seeing
just a few months ago
New York New Jersey are down 1.7%
respectively and moving beyond New York
in New Jersey we're seeing in Florida
for example though they have 12 cases
for every 1000 it is point to mortality
for every thousand cases in Arizona
point three deaths for every thousand
cases so we are seeing it's that our
therapeutics are working Matt
dexamethasone and convalescent plasma
and ROM decima are working and that's
something good and something that the
president takes note of wait three or
four weeks is such a short time period I
mean what specifically are you doing
there's a lot and I'm very glad that you
asked that because it is worth
highlighting the work that we're doing
each and every day for one we're surging
personnel to Arizona Texas California we
already have people working in Florida
surging rum Desa vir two states that are
seeing rising case numbers we're also
surging testing supplies to decrease
turnaround time these are several action
items that dr. Burks briefed me on
before coming out here on the White
House will be going to several states
this week dr. Burks in particular to
Louisiana Mississippi Alabama Georgia
South Carolina we've sent 19 HHS teams
to Metro plexus eight more coming this
week so we are aggressively on the
ground reacting to this virus more
encouraged to see the declining
mortality compared to a few months ago
thanks Kaylee why is the White House
trashing dr. pouchy and sending out
opposition research like memos to
reporters the president has gone off on
and on the sources in the past why not
have the guts to trash dr. pouchy with
your own names so President I'll refer
you back there's no opposition research
being dumped to reporters we were asked
a very specific question by The
Washington Post and that question was
President Trump noted that dr. Fauci had
made some mistakes and we provided a
direct answer to what was a direct
question the president made mistakes he
suggested at one point in Americans
inject themselves with disinfectants
that sort of thing why not send out
these notes to reporters about what
doctor thought you said
in the past with your names on a White
House official president has said he
doesn't trust anonymous sources and yet
you were sending out these notes to
reporters look I would note that in
terms of the president and his record on
coronavirus he stands by the actions and
the steps he's taken in this historic
response you have dr. Falchi who said
that the record of this president is
impressive I can't imagine that under
any circumstance that anybody could be
doing more and those are the words of
dr. Falchi we provided a direct response
to a direct question and that's about it
and to the notion that there's
opposition research and that there's
Falchi versus the president couldn't be
further from the truth
dr. Fauci and the president have always
had a very good working relationship
just a separate subject very quickly
does the president where the
administration plans to make it very
clear to the Russian Federation that
there should not be bounties placed on
the heads of American soldiers serving
in Afghanistan we make that clear each
and every day to every country around
the world that this president will
always stand by our law enforcement no
one's been tougher on Russia what you're
talking about is what I'm saying are us
you're getting what you're getting at of
course we tell each and every country
that but what you're getting at is
uncorroborated intelligence and you're
treating it as if it were true to this
day there are varying views on the
Russian bounty intelligence DoD NSC and
the OD and I all pointing that out you
know I'm not going to answer a question
based on unverified intelligence but
rest assured
every country in this world is put on
notice that bounties on the heads of US
troops is unacceptable and this
president will stand for US troops yes
when you compare us to other countries
we have the most testing in the world
when you compare us to other countries
on case fatality rate other
industrialized nations we're very low
and beating most countries if not all in
Europe so we're doing a lot on the world
stage did a lot right noted that we were
supposed to have a ventilator shortage
and as it turned
the US actually sent ventilators all
around the world so the US response has
been historic and by several metrics
including the three I just mentioned
we're beating the rest of the world okay
could you uh could you just clarify the
scope of Roger stones clemency a federal
judge is asking for this does it only
apply to prison time or does it also
include the two-year period of
supervised release I don't have the
exact details for you on that but I can
follow up what I will say is that the
Roger still in clemency was a very
important moment for justice in this
country you had a completely bogus
Russia witch hunts that found nothing
and in order to justify the waste of
taxpayer dollars you had robber molar
I'm charging people with processed
crimes and it's really curious to me
that with Roger stone you know he's
charged of false statements but mccabe
was charged of false statements lying to
federal investigators brennan false
statements to congress clapper false
statements to congress but last time I
checked they didn't have 29 FBI agents
wearing tactical gear showing up there
at their house in a pre-dawn raid
wielding m4 rifles sweeping across their
lawn as happened to Roger stone they
didn't have four agents using battering
rams breaking down their front door over
false statements and they didn't have
helicopters hovering over their houses
and two police police boats that roared
up instead McCabe and clapper and
Brennan and these guys are given
lucrative contracts books contributor
ships so there are really two standards
of justice in this country is Adam
Schiff noted fortunately doesn't have
the facts to back up the way he meant
that term Mario the president retweeted
something this morning implying that he
believes that he retweeted something
saying that the CDC is lying about the
corona virus in order to hurt his
chances of getting reelected does the
president believe that the CDC is lying
about mid-nineteen the president with
his antenna net retweet expressed his
displeasure with CDC some rogue
individuals leaking guidelines
prematurely you had a 63 page plan that
was leaked prematurely he believes that
that misleads the American public when
there are planning materials released
that are
in their fullest form and their best
form so that's what he was getting at
but overall the notion of the tweet was
to point out the fact that when we use
science we have to use it in a way that
is not political when you had a thousand
three hundred health experts sign a
letter not to condemn large crowds of
protesters but some same health experts
say churches need to stay shut down or
lock down protest somehow don't get the
same First Amendment rights as the
protests that we saw in our streets we
need to use science lean into science um
but not use it and cherry-pick it to fit
whatever our particular particular
political persuasion is yes in COCC he
does Mario Thank You Kaylee what we're
saying in Florida with the cases rising
is the president anticipating a
scaled-down version of the the
convention next month and if so is that
something that he would be concerned
with that would be a question for the
campaign but we still plan to move
forward with the convention here at the
White House but for particularity I
would point you to the RNC into the
campaign does the president still
appreciate the advice that he gets from
him certainly dr. Falchi is one of many
on the task force who provides advice
and I would note you know dr. Feld she
is an epidemiologist and infectious
disease expert and he provides his his
opinion there you also have other
experts like dr. McCain's cats who are
behavior behavioral health experts who
provide opinions about the holistic
health of the child and she's been a
voice for reopening schools and the
damage long long term lockdowns can do
you have dr. Ehrman stuffs alawi who's
working on the vaccines so there are a
number of scientists who are experts and
various issues and various specialties
but the president takes the full
opinions of the task force and the
varying opinions sometimes and moves
forward in a way he thinks is best for
this country like he did with the China
travel ban expires in about a week is
that going to be extended are you
talking about talking the carrot about
that
so no announcements now for our plans
with Canada yes Arizona has more new
cases of corona virus than any country
in the world more than the European
Union as a whole so in some by that
metric the United States not doing as
well as other countries in handling
no because when you lead the world in
testing that means that you identify
more cases when you I would know well
you talk about deaths I can give you
that particular information which dr.
Burks gave to me before running out here
which is in Arizona you have 17 cases
per 1000 population and point three
deaths per population which means our
therapeutics are working and we're in a
better place today than we were before
early-bird a schoolteacher in Arizona
died however when she was following all
the rules she wore a mask
she wore gloves he was teaching summer
school she got it died 200 teachers got
it and our ill her family or husband or
daughter I mean how do you tell parents
of school children that it's safe to say
they're kids back to school when
something like that happens
well I would point you to the words of
the CDC director who said children are
not very affected by this and typically
are not spreaders in this but I would
also point to the consequences of
staying close we have to look at the
holistic health of the child and when
you have according to HHS one-fifth of
all child abuse cases being reported by
teachers and educational staff we cannot
stay closed when you have DC family
child agency talking about a 62 percent
decrease in abuse cases being reported
you cannot stay closed when even the AAP
American Academy of Pediatrics talked
about morbidity and mortality if schools
stays shut down and seventy to eighty
percent of mental children with mental
health diagnoses receive their care in
schools the consequences are grave if we
stay shut down and there's a way for
essential workers to go back to work
just as our meatpacking facilities did
just as you all in the media are
essential workers we believe our
teachers are as well
the administration has said that the
goal of maximum pressure is to force a
lawn back to the negotiating tables you
can get a better deal is that still the
goal of maximum pressure and light
before the new trade and military
partnership between Iran and China what
evidence I have no information today to
update you on our Iran relationship
which stays the same today as it has
been yes Daniel
Chieko questions president Trump's
former chief of staff Mick Mulvaney he
still has a role in this administration
he said in an opportunity he's still at
a testing problem in the country that
heinous son at the week or five to some
days for results even president Trump's
former chief staff levels this criticism
doesn't that indicate do you have a
reaction
yeah reaction is that we've tested we
leave the world of testing we've done
more than forty million tests that's an
extraordinary number Admirals log gave
us an update yesterday that on Friday we
did over eight hundred thousand tests we
tripled quadrupled the number of tests
this is his exact quote we have and we
also have twelve thousand retail test
sites that are there and we're surging
testing and basically every specific
County that's having a problem and dr.
Burks was just walking me through pooled
testing which will be a way to process
tests at an even faster rate I'm so
leading the world in testing I would say
it means we're doing a pretty good job
yes a good question you know he made I
haven't talked to him since the specific
announcements been made I have talked to
him but not specifically on that but
last week his tweet made it clear that
these teams these teams named their
teams out of strength not weakness and
he talked about the Washington Redskins
and Cleveland Indians looking at
changing their names and he says that he
believes that the Native American
community would be very angry at this
and he does have pulling to back him up
there was a Washington Post poll from a
few years ago that ninety percent of
Native Americans say they're not
offended by the name it is reflective of
a 2004 poll and the Washington Post
notes that many of these Native
Americans voiced
admiration for the team name like
Barbara Bruce who said I'm proud of
being Native American and of the
Redskins I'm not ashamed of that at all
I like that name Gabriel Nez another
thirty nine twenty nine year old from
the Navajo community I really don't mind
it I like it and there are several other
comments like this in the Washington
Post
like to ask a question for my news
organization that can't be there because
of social distancing my question in
February when he was in Las Vegas
speaking to hope for prisoners the
president said he didn't want to use his
pardon power on Roger stone because he
thought it exonerated that didn't happen
and the president commuted the sentence
the same event the president said that
he might give a full pardon to John
Connor any convicted bank robbers who
served his time turned his wedding
around and started for prisoners if
they're going to be a pardon for John
Hunter and what about the more than 1300
pardon application sitting in the
apartment because there's part now that
people don't go to the part an
attorney's office they go through the
White House is that a good thing does it
mean that only politically connected
people to get part so I have no update
on John ponder it's absolutely not the
case that only those who are politically
connected get a pardon this president is
the president of criminal justice reform
this President did the first step back
this president has fought for those who
are given unduly harsh sentences more
than any Democrat who like to talk about
it never actually did it and in fact
when you compare the pardoning record of
this president with past presidents it's
quite striking that this presidents
given 36 Pardons and commutations
President Obama gave 1927 and when you
look at the nature of some of the
pardons given let's say under President
Clinton you talk about politically
connected pardons we can't get more
politically connected with pardons than
pardoning your brother Roger Clinton as
President Clinton did Susan mcdougal
one of your associates who was pardoned
for her role in whitewater
mark rich who gave $450,000 to the
Clinton library or at least his wife did
donated 1 million to Democrat campaigns
and then he gets a pardon from President
Clinton and notably a lot of these
pardons were when he was going out the
door so this president's used it
sparingly and instead focused on
criminal justice reform helping those
helping to rectify racial disparities in
our sentencing and Clinton and Obama
peers did a whole lot of partnering and
pardoning and in some cases politically
motivated it seems but didn't do a whole
lot to help the innocent people who have
served their time and been given unduly
harsh sentences I ever follow up for
someone who's who has heinous
question because the social distancing
this is from Jackson Richmond at the
Jewish news syndicate what's the
president stance on Israel planning to
apply sovereignty to parts of the West
Bank in to Democrats from Nancy Pelosi
to AOC when it's such a move would
undermine US national security and the
us-israel alliance I have no update
today on the current status but just
other than the president has been a
strong supporter of Israel Chris thanks
Kaylee we're coming up on the three-year
anniversary of the president tweeting he
ban transgender people from the military
in any capacity which led to the policy
currently in place last week a group of
116 lawmakers but they congresswoman
dubbed that a vote the administration
urging them to lift the policy with the
president reconsider the policy I
haven't talked to him about that
specific policy but this president is
proud that in 2019 we launched a global
initiative to end the criminalization of
homosexuality throughout the world he
has a great record when it comes to the
LGBT community the Trump administration
needs to ban on blood donations from gay
and bisexual men
I mean launched a plan to and they AIDS
epidemic by 2030 military is still in
place we have estimated 14,000 700
people we have full showing upwards of
70% of Americans support transgender
service and we have major medical and
psychological groups saying there's no
problem with transit people in the
military so what does having the policy
no updates for you but several of the
events that you cited like the Supreme
Court ruling I would refer you back to
justice Kavanagh who said we are judges
we're not members of Congress instead of
a hard-earned victory one through the
democratic process today's victory is
brought about by judicial dictates so
we'll always stand on the side of
correct
statutory interpretation can you really
say that the rise in testing accounts
for the rise in the number of cases
because the percentage of those testing
positive has risen sharply yes I would
say to this as we've always said that
there would be embers there would be
fires so we we readily acknowledge the
embers in the
fires that are around the country but we
also note that it's logic basic common
sense when you're testing more than any
country in the world you're going to
identify more cases we've tested more
than 40 million it means we will
identify more cases but when you see the
fact that mortality has come down per
thousand population and in a way that it
was it was not months ago in New York
and New Jersey it means that we have
become very adept at our therapeutics
and our ways of finding people in
communities rather than in hospitals
catching things early and moving forward
in a way that we know how to
aggressively attack this virus and keep
just now some of the trouble butter what
is the rationale now for keeping people
from Europe island and the UK from the
United States when they have a fraction
of the number of cases that you do in
the US the argument is we will always
put America first you know if you will
expand on the difference between this
time last month and now when it comes to
framing the discussion about law
enforcement last month and at that
roundtable he said that he would not
support defunding police and yet one
month later you still have Democrat
cities doing how does the White House
feel it should frame the debate now with
regards to defunding the police so that
a reasonable discussion can be had with
these Democrat cities we're trying to do
so yeah it's a very good question we
know that in Los Angeles when they
announced they would be defunding their
Police Department by 150 million they
basically immediately after saw a 250%
increase in homicides when you have
people out there like representative
Ilhan Omar saying we have to completely
dismantle the police and police our
cancer this is not how we should be
talking about our heroes you have most
egregious of all really congresswoman
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez saying defund
the police means to fund the police she
criticized of course the announcement of
1.5 billion dollars being taken down
from NYPD and this weekend you know when
faced with there were 28 shootings in
New York 600 percent increase from this
time last year you
representative Ocasio Cortez saying this
is just because people are trying to get
food with their families that is
preposterous
the reality is 63% of Americans in this
country fear that criticism of our
police departments will lead to no
public safety in their streets and 69%
of black Americans this is a real issue
when you call our police cancer when you
talk about dismantling them and then
this weekend in New York you see a
one-year-old killed in a stroller his
name was develop our Denar jr. and that
one-year-old will be in our prayers not
only that you see officers Garza and
Chavez and to your question about how we
should talk about the police and defund
the police movement the president stands
against the two officers ambushed this
weekend one of them officer Chavez his
daughter wrote a very touching tribute
online she said words cannot describe
the pain I'm in but I'm glad my dad is
at peace you are an amazing man and
anyone who ever came across you knew
that I'm going to miss you so much who
died doing what you love most you died a
hero
and those touching words were written by
Savannah Chavez and I know she received
vile and outrageous comments online that
were absolutely atrocious for a touching
sentiment to her dad I want to Savannah
to know your dad is a hero his Police
Department should never be defunded
because most of our police officers are
good hard-working men and women and
heroes much like Savannah's dad we'll be
praying for you Savannah thank you okay
what does the administration help you do
about the shootings in New York just
mention